Let's go to want to go next.
Let's go to.
Well, we've got to oh, how about Phillipi
from Indiana, Flippy from Indiana, you're
on the air.
Flippy from Indiana, please, on mute, you
are on the air, my friend.
And last opportunity for Flippy from Indiana
to unmuted and talk to me, I can you hear
me?
Yes, I can.
Hey, David, it's me.
I just was wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making it only bends.
Sorry if I if I've done making an omelet what
I'm making and only ends, you know, earning
season is over and it's time for you to show
us your zucchini.
That's very clever.
No, listen, I think I'd be more likely I'd
be more likely to show my my Granny Smith
apples than any Zuks, to be perfectly frank
Phillipi.
That works, too.
Yeah, I know, but I am on Cameo, which I think
is like the WorkSafe only fans, right?
Well, that works.
Thank you.
And by the way, where does the name Phillipi
come from?
Oh, just an alias online.
Oh.
Does it have any meaning?
No.
Does it relate to, like, a floppy disk, for
example?
Remember those five and a quarter inches?
Oh, it's supposed to be like flip floppy,
like a stupid way to call flip flops.
Oh, I got it.
By the way, are you cleaning a violin in the
background?
I know, bird.
Sorry.
Oh, it's OK.
All right.
Very good.
Well, listen, I really I really appreciate
the call, Flippy.
All right, thank you, have a good day.
All right, that is a perfect phone call.
So I think we're going to have to end on that.
I do apologize.
I wasn't able to get to every call, but we
got a wide variety from all over the world.
And we will certainly have to do something
with with that call.
Thanks, everybody.
I hope they get to more calls next time.
We will take a quick break and be right back
after this.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.